to think that we can't make organisms
that are more efficient than existing I
don't think is is correct because Nature
doesn't have DNA laser printers and you
do hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller for Reason
TV we are here with Austin Heinz CEO and
founder of Cambrian genomics a company
dedicated to making 3d printed DNA
Austin thank you very much for joining
us yeah
now when you say 3d printed DNA it
conjures a certain image in my mind what
exactly happens when you print it off -
are you just printing off this like goo
filled with DNA and and what happens to
it afterwards
I think 3d printing is a good analogy a
good way to understanding it with 3d
printing companies you have one company
like MakerBot and they actually sell
printers that people have on their
desktop then you have other companies
like shapeways where you send your
design and then they will print
something there and eventually send it
to you we're more of the shapeways model
but you're gonna design it on your home
computer but send it here and we're
gonna print out the DNA sequence unlike
with Shapeways we're not immediately
gonna send you your thing back in the
mail we're gonna send it somewhere else
to be tested to see if it's safe and
once it's seen as safe and you're able
to enough money into it to get over the
government hurdle then you'll be able to
actually get your get your product so
what is that product I mean someone
sends you what kind of DNA they want and
then you make it and you send them what
MakerBot you would print out and say
like a plastic dinosaur right
with cambrie and the ideas eventually
you'll be able to print out your own
little dinosaur that actually walks
across the table Oh what step in that
development process are you at now what
exactly do you produce here in this
laboratory right now we produce DNA for
the largest pharmaceutical companies in
the world as well as partnering with
plant companies currently glowing plant
is a product for sale at glowing plant
com that glows in the dark and we got
that through the USDA and the EPA
you're gonna be able to get the seeds
and grow it in your yard which is which
is exciting what your company is kind of
brought to this process so far as you've
dramatically brought the price point
down could you talk about that and roll
that robotics plays in that and the role
that automation plays and your ability
to bring that price point down well it's
directly related to another phenomena
that I think everyone's familiar with
it's just DNA sequencing 15 years ago no
one got their genome sequence because it
cost 6 billion dollars it was $1 a
letter that became super cheap because
it became made by a machine that could
make and read millions or billions of
strands of DNA at a time like the one
sitting right there will sequence 400
million strands in a single run what we
did is we simply leveraged sequencing
technology to reduce the price of making
DNA so that the cost now of making our
writing DNA letter
is the same cost as reading DNA letters
the idea that this power can eventually
are very soon be in the hands of the
masses right and some people yeah we saw
some of that play out in your
interaction with Kickstarter where you
were raising funds for creating the
glowing plants and Kickstarter banned
any further GMO project that will
probably change I imagine it's a new
technology not a lot of people have
familiarity with it our goal really will
be to put this in the hands of everyone
- not necessarily to make money but - to
make this a more common thing huge
percentage of what we eat already is GMO
there is a growing fear among certain
segments of society and even people in
government that people will alter our
environment our ecosystem in ways that
are unpredictable and possibly dangerous
does that concern you when it comes to
this event yes so safety is a huge
concern and security to think that we
can't make organisms that are more
efficient than existing I don't think is
is correct because Nature doesn't have
DNA laser printers and we do and so we
really need to to build a system whereby
the things that we create do not work
right into the wild and the way to do
that is by changing the codon table like
this is all protein or it's organized by
protein protein is 20 amino acids and so
if we introduce artificial amino acids
into synthetic creatures and then we
there's no source of that in nature that
means they can't survive unless we're
feeding them if we're thinking this of
this in terms of 3d printing we're
essentially the the means of production
are kind of brought way down and
ownership is brought to the individual
level even how do you see that shifting
the way science is done in America oh
yeah
so virtualization is really going to
take off we see things like oculus rift
and augmented reality and the Ed Snowden
robot from Ted and it's going to be
almost like being there and so you'll be
able to go from idea to finish product
without ever touching anything physical
and that's exciting because that's not
how things work now you go to an
academic lab it's miserable
they're spending 90% of their time
cutting and pasting DNA from different
creatures that they collect from across
the country and pasting them together we
want that to be 95 percent design
analysis and 5% manual work if there's
any manual work your your company has
glowing plants that are available for
people to design and even purchase one
of your companies has even promoted a
probiotic that allows dog crap to smell
like bananas so what is the relationship
that you see there between consumerism
and science well what's great is with
consumer products is that they can be
crowd funded so the plant $5,000
investment half a million in six weeks
over a million revenue total since since
the onset
that means a couple people can get into
the game with a tiny budget a budget
just large enough to make a video and if
there's interest then they can use that
money not only to print the DNA but to
make the organism and then pay for the
expensive lawyers and everything else to
get it through the regulatory agencies
how do you feel generally about the
regulatory environment of the biotech
space do you feel like it's about right
is it too restrictive too restrictive in
certain areas or what's wrong you know
it's not in the United States we're
pretty open on plants but we're really
locked down on people oh yeah whereas
you go to Europe and it's the opposite
they're really locked down on point
plants but they're open on people in the
UK they're having three parent babies in
the near future we're gonna have lots
and lots of people walk you know humans
walking around Europe that are
genetically modified or genetically
modified organisms it's also funny is
that many of those people are going to
be a part of anti GMO organizations so
you're likely going to have the
president of some anti GMO organization
be a GMO and so you'll have a
genetically modified organism protesting
the existence of genetically modified
organisms which is gonna be really funny
in time all of us will likely need to
print out and fix our DNA the issue with
that is it's going to be unique our DNA
is unique unless you have an identical
twin your DNA is unique and it's wrong
everyone's wrong
everyone's messed up and everyone needs
to be fixed or will need to be fixed at
some point you'll either get cancer or
some other disease so how do we do that
given the current a regulatory
environment with the FDA the FDA doesn't
approve things one-off they approve like
a small molecule that you can give to
everyone on earth but everyone's unique
and that model will no longer work it's
going to be very very specific and very
individual because now we have these
tools that are very very precise I mean
with this machine we can sequence a
whole human genome in a single run
we can know all of your letters with the
machines in the other room we can print
out all the letters and so that power
never existed before and so regulation
on the medical side of things is going
to need to catch up to that on a
personal level what excites you most
about what this technology allows us to
do right now and looking forward in the
next three to five years what aspect
kind of gets you the most excited we're
getting really close to the point where
we can not only know our code and all
the code of everything that's alive on
the planet like neo and the matrix it's
all just everything that's alive is just
code and all the food 10-15 years ago we
didn't have that now we do wouldn't it
be more exciting if not only we could
know what everything is but sort of
change it by snapping our fingers and
reimagine an entirely new world around
us where everything is programmable
everything is is rewritable everything
can be modified everything can be made
better and the individual has the power
to do that the individual has a power to
know themselves like they've never known
themselves before to read their entire
code it really changes Society culture
religion changes how we think about
ourselves as humans changes about how we
think about the environment changes how
we think about our future and the
purpose of life itself
it is extremely profound but it all
comes from something very simple which
is the cost per letter of DNA awesome
guys thank you very much for talking to
us yeah for reason TV I'm Zack